ever since he began his effort to buy
the Democratic nomination Michael
Bloomberg has been attacked by all sides
for these stop-and-frisk policies he
used for 12 years as mayor of New York
City under those policies police were
encouraged to stop and question
individuals on the streets of New York
and then frisk them if they suspect them
of committing criminal activity
Bloomberg himself has apologized for all
of this he says he's embarrassed by the
existence of the policy the Trump
campaign and as many surrogates have
joined him in that they've partnered
with the left to call Bloomberg a racist
for stop and frisk and that's
understandable of course it's election
season and every politician every
campaign knows it's useful to an attack
an opponent where he's vulnerable but
let's take three steps back politics
aside the only problem Bloomberg has
with stop and frisk is that he's
apologizing for it stopping frisk isn't
racist even his crime fell in the city
the most dangerous parts of New York
we're still filled with volatile young
men many of them gang members carrying
illegal guns stopped and first found
those guns by the thousands while gang
members learned to leave their illegal
weapons at home if they didn't want to
go to jail stop and frisk also found a
lot of illegal drugs and took them as
well as their dealers off the streets
did most searches discover a crime no
they didn't but 12% of all stop and
frisk searches the frisk part did
discover a crime and that's a remarkable
number for an otherwise harmless search
imagine if 12% of all TSA searches
discovered a gun or a bomb or other
criminal behavior would you want TSA
abolished as wasteful and excessive no
you wouldn't it'd be a huge success
you stop and frisk racist well unlike al
Sharpton and the black lives matter
movement of the new bail law in New York
or the criminal justice reform bill
we're all supposed to like stop and
frisk actually saved lives hundreds of
lives and those lives are overwhelmingly
young black and Hispanic people in 1990
New York City had more than two thousand
two hundred murders that's a lot via
Rudy Giuliani left office there were 649
murders under Mayor Michael Bloomberg
that number was cut in half again it
dropped to 322 murders a year in a city
of 8 million so New York wasn't just
safer it was this single safest major
city and
maybe in the world outside Tokyo and you
know who agreed with that Donald Trump
just four years ago in a debate with
Hillary Clinton then candidate Trump
said this in New York City stop and
frisk we had 2,200 murders and stop and
frisk brought it down to five hundred
murders five hundred murders a lot of
murders
hard to believe five hundred is like
supposed to be good but we went from two
thousand two hundred to five hundred and
it was continued on by Mayor Bloomberg
and it was terminated by current mayor
but stop and frisk had a tremendous
impact on the safety of New York City
tremendous beyond belief so when you say
it has no impact it really did it had a
very very big impact it's so funny
because the essence of stop for the
first was taking illegal guns off the
street something Democrats say they're
for but no they just want to take your
guns out of your closet because you
didn't vote for them in Trump's
Republican convention speech later in
2016 he laid out the consequences of
rolling back effective criminal justice
policies like stop and frisk decades of
progress made in bringing down crime are
now being reversed by this
administration's rollback of criminal
enforcement in this race for the white
house I am the law and order candidate
man was that true nothing affects the
lives of normal people people without
power more than high crime rates and if
you haven't lived it
say a prayer you never have to because
it's the worst thing you can imagine in
2016 Donald Trump understood that he
didn't care about sneering elites in
their gated communities calling him
racist he stood behind law and order
policies that made life better for
everyone everyone of all backgrounds
ethnicities colors all Americans and it
worked
Trump did better than Mitt Romney did
with black and Hispanic voters and
that's part of the reason and that could
happen again
by the way Bloomberg errs on his apology
tour because apparently thinks he has to
say it because he wants to win non-white
voters but apparently he hasn't looked
at the real numbers data for progress
polled Democratic voters about their
feelings of Mike Bloomberg when they
brought up the question of stop and
frisk the only group that didn't like it
was white Democrats black Democrats felt
the same Bloomberg Hispanic and Asian
Democrats said they were more likely to
vote for Mike Bloomberg after hearing
about stop and frisk it's not really
surprising nobody in America of all
races like crime everyone wants less of
it the only people who feel differently
are white liberals so why are they
bossing us around we shouldn't let them
but for some reason the Republican Party
is doing exactly that when they cede
stop-and-frisk to the left where's this
going exactly four years now Republicans
be denouncing bans on public urination
as bigotry please all Americans deserve
to live in a safe clean law-abiding
pleasant country and if there's any
reason to vote Republican it's because
they stand up for that and when they see
standing up for that what's the point